THE IS NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVIN NOTICES THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT
ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA. BAUER K.
HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES CHEN
CHOI COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALLY DAILY DAVIES LARA MIKE
LONGER VINCE FONG FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LOUIS
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY. MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH STONE
TAKING VELADERO AS THE APPROVED
ROCK VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER
WICKS WILSON WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS. IN THE REAR CHAMBER
AND IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
STAND FOR THE PRAYER. TODAY'S
PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN IMAM MR. IN THE NAME OF GOD
. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALL POWERFUL GOD. YOU
KNOW THE HEARTS OF ALL PEOPLE.
AND GOD ALL THINGS UNDER YOUR
POWERFUL PROTECTION. HELP US TO
ALWAYS ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR
GREATNESS IN COMPARISON TO OUR
OWN WEAKNESS. AND GUIDE US AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TO MAKE YOUR
WILL TO BE DONE ON THIS EARTH.
BLESS OUR NATION WHICH IS
FOUNDED ON TRUST IN YOU. MAKERS
ALWAYS GRATEFUL FOR THE FREEDOMS
AND BLESSINGS WE ENJOY IN THIS
GREAT LAND OF PROSPERITY AND
MINDFUL OF THE PRINCIPLES OF
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
WHICH OUR FOUNDING FATHERS AND
MOTHERS HAVE INSTILLED IN US. IN
YOUR DIVINE MERCY GUIDE OUR
NATION'S LEADERS OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND ESPECIALLY THESE
MEN AND WOMEN HERE TODAY. ALWAYS
<c.yellow>EEPING IN MIND THAT THESE</c>
AMAZING PRINCIPLES UPON WHICH
OUR COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED. NEVER
FORGET THAT YOU CALL US. DID YOU
CALL US ALL NOT TO WORK FOR SO
GLORIA. TO SERVE THE GREATER
GOOD AND ALWAYS MAKE THEM WORTHY
OF THE WORK ENTRUSTED TO THEM.
WE ASK YOUR GOD. TO GIVE US THE
COURAGE TO WORK FOR PEACE. THAT
THE EXAMPLE WE GIVE MAY LEAD
OTHERS TO SINCERELY DESIRED THE
FURTHERANCE OF THE RIGHT TO THE
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS FOR ALL
MANKIND. I MEAN. YES OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEYARTO AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER SAY ART. THANK YOU
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THAT RECITING
THE PLEDGE. READY AGAIN.
DILIGENCE TO THE FLAG. OF THE
UNITED STATES OF. ZERO ONE-
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY SEAMUS SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY MARCH SEVENTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY
MET AT NINE AM THE AUTOMOBILE
BONTA SYSTEM SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE
OF THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF
CLERK SHE PART OF THE DEATHS
READING CLERK DAVID BOWMAN
READING WILL CALL THE ROLL CALL
THANK CALL THE ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES MOVES AND MR.
GALLAGHER SECONDS. THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
EXHORTATIONS AMPUTATIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. WILL BE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED. IN THE JOURNAL. MS
REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
pBENNETT AND WILSON TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY THE GUESTS WILL BE
SEATED AT THEIR DESKS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE. AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY THREE SEYARTO FOR
THE PRIVACY CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE TO THE MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE. AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR THREE OF US
FROM THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. TO
THE BUSINESS OF PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SIXTEEN
NINETY UP WITH ONE FROM THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
TWO FOURTEEN CRISTINA GARCIA.
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
ARAMBULA FROM THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY TWO MCCARTY FROM THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY FIVE BERMAN
FOR THE PRIVACY CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE LOW
FROM THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES TO SAID BILLS PENDING
REFERRAL FROM OTHER COMMITTEES.
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
TO NOTICE AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE CARILLO FOR THEIR HEARING
ON WEDNESDAY APRIL TWENTY
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
AND PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB SEVENTY
TWENTY THREE PATTERSON FOR THEIR
HEARING ON WEDNESDAY APRIL
TWENTY PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION ON ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT. SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
TO RISE SO TO ALLOW THE BILL TO
BE MOVED TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED AND
THE BILL IS MOVED TO AN ACTIVE
FILE. MY MOVE TO STRIKE ITEM
NUMBER ONE FROM THE FILE. SECOND
BY MISTER WARD. EVERS IS A
PROCEDURAL MOTION REQUIRING
FORTY ONE VOTES CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF THE IT IS
OUT OF THAT MAJORITY LEADERS
ASKED FOR AND I AM A REPUBLICAN
LEADER ASKING FOR NOW ALL THOSE
VOTERS OUT OF ALL. TAKES. FORTY
ONE. CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLLING
TIED TO VOTE IS FORTY THREE
KNOWS FIFTEEN THE ADDAMS
STRICKEN FROM THE FILE. MEMBERS
WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY. WE HAVE A NEWLY
ELECTED MEMBER FOR THE ELEVENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT PLEASE WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAURIE WILL SEND
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL STAND IS
JOINED BY HER HUSBAND CHAU VIRUS
WILL SAN AND FRIEND SHAKIRA AND
YOUR SENATE PASTOR A WREATH THAT
TOMLINSON LET'S WELCOME THEM TO
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS WHILE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL SEND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON WE WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY A FEW WORDS TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES FROM YOUR DESK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL SEND YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY IT'S SUCH
AN HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY AND
THIS- CHAMBER AND TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE WITH EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU AND WE ALL ARE HERE BECAUSE
THE VOTER CENTERS HERE WE'RE ALL
HERE TO DO GOOD WORK. AND I'M
HERE TO DO THAT WITH YOU I NOTED
YESTERDAY AND MY PROGRAM I SEE
MY ROLE AS A COLLABORATOR AND I
DEFINITELY LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING WITH EACH OF YOU
ON THE HOW YOU CAN BEST SERVE
YOUR DISTRICT AND ME BEING A
PART OF THAT- SO THAT BECAUSE IF
WE DO THAT TOGETHER. REALLY IT
LEADS TO THE BETTERMENT OF OUR
ENTIRE STATE AND WE KNOW THAT AS
OUR STATE IS THE LEADER IN THE
NATION AND WHERE WE GO THE
NATION GOES AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO- DOING THAT WORK WITH EACH OF
YOU AND MEETING WITH EACH OF YOU
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR DIS
ALL THE WARM. GREETINGS THAT
I'VE GOTTEN OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS AND ESPECIALLY OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE ON TO
SECOND READING. SECOND READING
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN WITH THE
MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WITH A MINUTE SEVENTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT WITH A MEMBERS
TWENTY TO FORTY FOUR NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN WITH A
MEMBERS EIGHTEEN FORTY FOR THE
MOMENT SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX.
EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY FIVE TWENTY ONE
OF THE MOMENT SIXTEEN NINETY
WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY TO THIRTY
WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY THREE
NINETY THREE WITH A- TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY SIX TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
MINUTES TWENTY SEVENTY TWO OF
THE MEMBERS SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
WITH MEMBERS. TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
WITH A MINUTES TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE WITH A MEMBERS
213-727-3520 THREE SEVENTY FOUR
OVER THE MINUTES. SIXTEEN
NINETEEN WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY TWO WITH MEMBERS
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS TWENTY SIX AWAY WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
MINUTES. TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX
OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO WITH A MINUTE SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. 1-042-056-2630 FIVE
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO SEVENTEEN
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO.
701-876-1890. THREE NINETEEN OH
SEVEN NINETEEN TWENTY SIX
NINETEEN FORTY SIX TWENTY ONE
FORTY FIVE. 225-622-7020 THREE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY THREE THIRTY
TWO. 243-124-3320 FIVE FIFTY TWO
MINUTES TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR
MEMBERS TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN
OF THE MEMBERS. TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED WITH A MEMBER TENNYSON
MIDDLE TWENTY THREE FIFTY FIVE
THE MINUTES. ALL WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND- TO. IT MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE WE HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL SPECIAL GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT
IS JOINED BY HIS GRANDSON STEVEN
MY ORGANS STEVENS FRIEND SHOWS
OF THE SO MORROW WELCOME YOUNG
MEN TO THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
ITEMS FIFTY NINE. THROUGH
SEVENTY TWO PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE
THIS IS A C. R. ONE SIXTY EIGHT
BY MS REYES MEMBERS. PLEASE GIVE
ME AS RAISE YOUR ATTENTION THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE ACR
ONE SIXTY EIGHT CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO RAMADAN. MS REYES. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. ACR ONE
SIXTY EIGHT RECOGNIZES RAMADAN A
MONTH IT IS IMPORTANT TO NEARLY
A QUARTER OF THE WORLD'S
POPULATION AND OVER ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. FIVE DAYS AGO WAS
THE FIRST DAY OF FASTING FOR
CALIFORNIA MUSLIMS. AND FOR
MUSLIMS AROUND THE WORLD AS THEY
BEGAN THE THIRTY DAYS OF FASTING
FROM SUN UP. TO SUN DOWN FOR THE
MONTH OF RAMADAN. RAMADAN IS A
TIME FOR REFLECTION AND
SPIRITUAL DISCIPLINE THAT
EMBODIES WHAT WE ALL HOLD DEAR
WHICH IS DEVOTION TO FAITH. TIME
WITH FAMILY AND SERVICE TO THE
COMMUNITY. A KEY COMPONENT OF
RAMADAN IS TO EXPERIENCE HUNGER
AND THIRST TO DEVELOP EMPATHY
FOR THOSE FACING HARDSHIPS DUE
TO POVERTY. THIS EMPATHY EVOLVES
INTO AN OBLIGATION TOWARD
CHARITABLE GIVING AND COMMUNITY
SERVICE FOR THOSE IN NEED.
THROUGH THAT SPIRIT OF SERVICE
MANY. MUSLIM ORGANIZATIONS
STATEWIDE PROVIDE FOOD
DISTRIBUTION OTHER RESOURCES TO
THOSE IN NEED. OUR OWN ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN. LEADS
AN ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
FOOD BOXES TO THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES IN THE SACRAMENTO AND
SURROUNDING REGIONS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR FAITH. THESE EFFORTS
ARE VITAL IN OUR STTE WHERE AS
MANY AS ONE IN FIVE CALIFORNIANS
CURRENTLY STRUGGLE WITH FOOD
INSECURITY. THE MUSLIM AMERICAN
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO BE A
PILLAR OF CALIFORNIA MAKING OF
CALIFORNIA. MAKING RAMADAN PART
OF THE FABRIC OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSITY AND HISTORY. MEMBERS I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON ACR ONE
SIX EIGHT SO THAT WE CAN
COLLECTIVELY WHERE'S OUR MUSLIM
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS A BLESSED
RAMADAN. THANK YOU MS REYES MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR
ONE SIXTY EIGHT I WANT TO EXTEND
THE WARMEST WISHES- AND RAMADAN
GREETINGS RAMADAN MUBARAK
RAMADAN KAREEM TO ALL OF OUR
WITH SOME FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS
HERE. IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND AROUND THE WORLD. AND I KNOW
WE ALL OF US I THINK- ARE SO
IMPRESSED BY THE INCREDIBLE
DEVOTION AND SELF DISCIPLINE THE
DEVOTION TO FAITH AND TO
COMMUNITY. THAT IT TAKES FOR
MUSLIM NEIGHBORS TO OBSERVE
RAMADAN TO FAST EVERY SINGLE DAY
WITHOUT FOOD OR WATER. AND I
READ AN INCREDIBLE ARTICLE LAST
NIGHT IN THE WASHINGTON POST
ABOUT ALL OF THE SERVICE WORKERS
MUSLIM SERVICE WORKERS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO WORK IN
THE FOOD INDUSTRY WHO PREPARE
FOOD ALL DAY WHILE THEY'RE
FASTING AN INCREDIBLE SELF
DISCIPLINE THAT THAT TAKES. AND
ALSO AS OUR MAJORITY LEADER
SPOKE ABOUT THE WAY IN WHICH OUR
MUSLIM COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS SO FOCUSED ON
GIVING BACK I HAD A DAY OF
SERVICE IN MY DISTRICT ON
SUNDAY. AND I WAS SO IMPRESSED
AND DELIGHTED TO SEE SO MANY
MEMBERS OF OUR MUSLIM COMMUNITY
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY THEY
CAME OUT EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE
FASTING EVEN THOUGH THEY
COULDN'T DRINK WATER TO COME DO
ACTS OF SERVICE TO WORK. AND
THAT KIND OF SPIRIT OF COMMUNITY
SPIRIT OF GIVING BACK I THINK
REFLECTS THE BEST OF WHAT THE
COMMUNITY IS ALL ABOUT IN THE
BEST OF WHAT THE VALUES THAT WE
ASPIRE TO HEAR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO. ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
C. SAID RAMADAN. THANKS MISS
GABRIEL SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. MS
RATIONING BECAUSE WE WISH THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I THINK TODAY
HAVING THESE YOUNG MEN WITH US
TODAY YOU GET TO LEARN ABOUT
RAMADAN AND I HOPE YOU TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO GREET OUR
MOM TODAY THE VERY SPECIAL-
BLESSING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE HURT
HIM WITH US ALSO. AND WITH THAT
I ALSO THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS THIS RACES THAT
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR ONE
SIXTY EIGHT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CO AUTHORS ON ACR. ONE
SIXTY EIGHT. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY SIX CO
AUTHORS HAD WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
WITHOUT OBJECTION TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE HR. ONE HUNDRED
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE
HR ONE HUNDRED O'DONNELL CLERK
WILL READ. HOUSE WAS SOLUTION
ONE HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL RELATIVE TO CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK. MISTER
O'DONNELL THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TO MOVE IT SO.
THAT'S A GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
DAY INCOME BY THE LANGUAGE OF
THE CAMBODIAN PEOPLE I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT HR ONE
HUNDRED WHICH RECOGNIZES APRIL
ELEVENTH THROUGH APRIL
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO S.
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK
. FROM APRIL SEVENTEENTH
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE TO JANUARY
SEVENTH NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
THE COMMUTER RUSE PERPETRATED
ONE OF THE MOST HEINOUS CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY. NEARLY TWO
MILLION PEOPLE DIED UNDER THIS
EXTREMIST RULE WHICH IMPOSED A
RUTHLESS AGENDA OF FORCED LABOR.
FOUGHT CONTROL AND MASS
EXECUTIONS UPON THE CAMBODIAN
PEOPLE. AFTER THE OVERTHROW OF
THE CAREER ROUGE REGIME IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
CAMBODIANS CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES AS REFUGEES. MY COMMUNITY
OF LONG BEACH IS KNOWN AROUND
THE WORLD AS THE HOME TO THE
LARGEST CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY
OUTSIDE OF SOUTHEAST ASIA. THE
CAMBODIAN PEOPLE HAVE DRAWN FROM
THEIR CULTURAL HISTORY TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES AND
COMMUNITIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND CERTAINLY MAKE LONG BEACH A
BETTER PLACE. CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE
MEMORIAL WEEK HONORS THE
SURVIVORS AND THEIR DESCENDANTS
FOR THEIR GREAT COURAGE AND FOR
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE
AND OUR COUNTRY. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME IN RECOGNIZES THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THIS COURAGEOUS
AND RESILIENT COMMUNITY TRULY
GREAT PEOPLE. TODAY I'D LIKE TO
SAY WE ARE ALL A LITTLE BIT
CAMBODIAN AS WE CELEBRATE THESE
GREASE GREAT PEOPLE AND
RECOGNIZE THEIR TRAGIC PAST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND REQUEST FOR THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISTER DONNA
. AND MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS GENOCIDE IS AN
ATTEMPT TO EXTERMINATE A PEOPLE.
AND A CULTURE. WE SPEAK UP TO
SAY NEVER AGAIN BUT THE TRAGEDY
OF GENOCIDE COMES UP OVER AND
OVER. IN MANY PLACES AROUND THE
WORLD TODAY THERE ARE PEOPLE AND
CULTURES IN PERIL OF
EXTERMINATION. THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP STANDING
UP. TODAY WE COMMEMORATE THE
TERRIBLE LOSSES EXPERIENCED BY
ANCIENT CULTURES IN CAMBODIA
INFLECT INFLICTED BY THE CAMARO
ROUGE IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
I THANK THE MEMBER FROM LONG
BEACH FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
TO US. IN HIS DISTRICT AND IN
MIND THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO
LEFT CAMBODIA TO SETTLE IN
CALIFORNIA. THOSE REFUGEES CAME
HERE HOPING FOR PEACE AND
ACCEPTANCE. THEY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED ALL CONTRIBUTED A
LOT TO CALIFORNIA. FOR THEM AND
FOR EVERY CULTURE THAT COMES
HERE SEEKING A HAVEN WE WILL
MUST REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED IN
CAMBODIA. THESE REFUGEES NEED
THAT PEACE THEY DESERVE OUR
ACCEPTANCE. CAMBODIAN GENOCIDAL
MEMORIAL WEEK ISA SPECIFIC
RECOGNITION OF THE TERRORS.
CAMBODIAN PEOPLE EXPERIENCED A
DECADE AGO. AS WE COMMEMORATE
THAT TODAY WE CAN USE THE
OCCASION TO REFLECT ON OTHER
ASYLUM SEEKERS. SEEKING TO COME
TO CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA IS
NEVER TOO FULL FOR REFUGEES IN
NEED. WHEN THEY SEE OPPRESSION
IN THEIR HOME COUNTRIES WE
SHOULD STAND WE SHOULD SHOW THEM
HOPE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN VOTING I AN HR ONE
HUNDRED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THE AUTHORS ASSET THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. TALK ABOUT THE ROLE. HR
ONE THIS IS CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. CLICK WELL DOES
THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAME. THE EYES HAVE IT. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WE HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR.
TODAY THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
BEFORE WE VOTE WE WILL TAKE A
FILE ITEMS NINETY SIX AND- ONE
OH ONE THROUGH ONE OH THREE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADDING CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL READ THE RESOLUTIONS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLAN RELATIVE TO BLACK APRIL
MEMORIAL MONTH SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY ONE BY CENTER
BATES AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
PUBLIC HEALTH SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY SIX BY CENTER
HER TADO AND OTHERS GO TO THE
SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD. AWARENESS MONTH AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
REDUCING SEVENTY NINE BY CENTER-
CHAU POLK AND OTHERS ROTH OF THE
GIRL SCOUTS OF THE USA. CLERK
WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE TO ALLOW
ANY MEMBER ADAM. RESOLUTION THIS
IS A CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT. CO
AUTHORS FOR THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CLARK WELL
. CLOSE ROLE THERE SIXTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED. MOVING TO A VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITSELF
THE SAME EVER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING AND HEARING NINE. COOKERY
THE SECOND I CAN CHECK OUT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NINETY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
AN ACT RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. AND CLERK WILL OPEN THE
WRONG THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THIS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
THIS IS YOU CONSENT CALENDAR.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS A TOPIC FOR
ME READ. REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN TWENTY FIVE I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO SYMBOL SIXTEEN FORTY ONE
I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO CYNICAL
SIXTEEN FIFTY THREE I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN
SIXTY ONE. I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SYMBOL EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR. I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FORTY TWO. I SIXTY FOUR
TO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. BY SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTEEN I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FOUR I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SUM IT WILL TWENTY
EIGHT TWELVE I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY WILL NINETEEN
SIXTY. I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
THIRTY C. I SIXTY FORECLOSURE
AND THE URGENCY I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO ON THE BILL. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
ONE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO CYNICAL
RESOLUTION SEVENTY SIX I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY NINE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO IN SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
SIX. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO MISTER
KALRA. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR AN
ANNOUNCEMENT MEMBERS. MISTER
KALRA. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AS WE HEAD HOME
TO OUR DISTRICTS DURING THE
SPRING RECESS I WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO WISH
EVERYONE A HAPPY BY SAKE AND
ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO TAKE PART
IN CELEBRATIONS ON THURSDAY
APRIL FOURTEENTH BY SAKE IS
OBSERVED BY AS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT DAYS OF SICK
AMERICANS ARE SICK HISTORY AND
IS AS OBSERVED BY MANY SOUTH
ASIAN CALIFORNIANS AND THE
INDIAN DIASPORA THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD- THERE WOULD LIKELY BE. I
THINK EACH EVERY ONE OF YOU
EITHER HAS A GOOD WATER IN YOUR
DISTRICT OR NEAR YOUR DISTRICT
STARTING COULD YOU TO SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON THIS WEEKEND TO
CELEBRATE MY SAKE OR ON THE
FOURTEENTH ITSELF- YOU WILL BE
REMEMBER. MANY REMEMBER WE'VE-
AND DINNER WOULD HAVE TURBAN DAY
HE AT THE CAPITOL THAT WAS A
SOME OF MY SAKE. I FORWARD TO
BRING THAT BACK. ONCE AGAIN HOLD
. IN THE NEAR FUTURE BUT IN THE
MEANTIME I WANT TO WISH EVERYONE
A VERY HAPPY BY SAKE WILL BE
VOTING ON THE RESOLUTION. RIGHT
WHEN WE GET BACK- THANK YOU ALL
SO MUCH HAVE A GREAT RECESSED.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS SPRING
RECESS BEGINS UPON ADJOURNMENT
THROUGH APRIL SEVENTEENTH.
MONDAY APRIL EIGHTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION IS A ONE PM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING A
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES MR
GALLAGHER. SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY APRIL EIGHTEENTH AT ONE
PM THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND
ENJOY YOUR SPRING RECESS MEMBERS.